the consistent theme we're discovering
in chemistry that everything is about
random bumps between molecules and when
they bump randomly into each other a lot
of different things can happen in terms
of knocking different parts of the
molecules off of each other and bonding
to different things and this this
includes pure water which for the most
part one would think is a pretty stable
substance and it really is but it turns
out let's say if we start with two water
molecules and when I put a 2 here in any
of these is going to turn into an
equilibrium equation I could it could
represent two molecules it could
represent two moles of molecules what
matters is just the ratios in these
equations and I think you know that but
let me just draw two for for an example
so let's say I have a the oxygen end
let's say I have another oxygen here
they both are attached to some
hydrogen's hydrogen's they're sharing
electrons with some hydrogen's here and
we know that oxygen is a lot more
electronegative than hydrogen so it hogs
all the electrons and what that creates
is a partial positive charge at the
hydrogen side of the water molecule
they're almost naked protons being
attached to the water molecule so this
is positive here and then the oxygen
size have a partial negative charge
because they're hogging all the
electrons and this bond between the
negative side of the oxygen molecules on
the positive side of another oxygen
molecule this is called a hydrogen bond
and this is what keeps water together
and what keeps it you know definitely
it's liquid or solid States and it's
solid States these bonds become kind of
they only stay together in some lattice
structure and liquid state they can kind
of break and form new ones but they keep
them close to each other rubbing against
each other now it turns out if you just
have exactly the right set of
circumstances that if one oxidase you
know I this isn't the exact set of
circumstances but I think you can
imagine if this moved just exactly close
enough it had enough kinetic energy to
move right past this one there's some
probability there's some probability and
I'll draw an equilibrium reaction here
because that is what we are dealing with
the equilibrium reaction there's some
probability that this hydrogen right
here gets stuck to this guy he gets so
close and maybe this guy bounces in some
other weird way that we get left with
let me draw the same two characters two
oxygens actually let me draw the second
guy let's say that he's just he just
somehow passed the other guy so he had
some movement all right let's say he
moved in that direction that's you know
this is obviously not scientific but it
gives you a narrative around what could
happen so this is this guy's hydrogen
protons and this was attracted to this
oxygen side and if just just to the
right circumstances remember everything
here is probabilistic there's always a
probability of almost anything happening
this guy can get attached to this
electron to this to the negative side of
this water molecule or the water side
and then this guy is only left with one
hydrogen right here and then this
molecule as a whole this is Oh H
hydroxide and it has a minus charge
right because now we've water was a
neutral molecule that you had just as
many protons and electrons now we have
one less proton than electron so in this
case you just just the hydrogen at just
the hydrogen nucleus itself which is
just a proton because we learned that
hydrogen doesn't have any neutrons in
its normal form this is essentially a
proton when we draw a hydrogen it gets
bumped off or scraped off and ends up on
this water molecule so this guy lost a
proton has the same number of electrons
so he now has a negative charge this guy
has the same number of electrons but now
he's got an extra proton so he has a
positive charge so this is h3o with a
positive charge and this little version
right here we gave a water molecule and
it somehow gains an extra an extra a
hydrogen proton or hydrogen atom this is
called hydronium hydronium hydronium and
this process where water can kind of
spontaneously and I'm not saying that
water will you know a whole glass of
water that's going to happen it's
actually happening to a very small
number of molecules that if you view
this as an equilibrium reaction the when
you have two waters this is much more
that the reaction is much more weighted
in in the leftward direction but this
can happen and that's what the whole
point of this is
is to think about but this process is
called Auto ionization because you just
have water by itself and just by some
random circumstances if some molecules
bumping into each other just right some
subset of the water will ionize like
this where one part will lose a will
lose a proton and the other part will
gain one so this is auto-ionization let
me write that down
Auto ionization and of course this is an
equilibrium reaction so now these guys
might go bump into two other things and
become water again or maybe they'll bump
into each other again and they'll become
water so it goes back and forth there so
there's some equilibrium concentration
of this and let me write it as a proper
equilibrium reaction so you could have
two may be moles of water molecules they
are in equilibrium with h3o positive and
all of these are in an aqueous solution
and that's a bit of a redundancy because
aqueous solution means that your
dissolved in water so of course water is
a developed dissolved in water but then
h3o dissolved in water so all around
here you have water molecules these
aren't this isn't an isolation you have
gazillions of water molecules all around
plus o h o h minus aqueous now sometimes
you will see this exact reaction written
as you'll see that exact reaction
written is this and it's important that
you realize it's the same thing
h2o in equilibrium with just one
hydrogen ion popping off everything is
in an aqueous solution let me write that
down everything is being dissolved in
water aqueous solution plus o h minus in
an aqueous solution and these are this
equation right here this right here and
what i wrote at the top and let me write
let me cut and paste this so you can see
them at the same time so let me copy go
down here and paste this these are
essentially equivalent although the
second equation right here describes
what exactly happens so the first
equation is creating a picture that you
have one water molecule and there's some
small probability that one of its high
just pop off and you're just left with a
hydrogen and a hydroxide which is just
an oxygen and a hydrogen atom together
but the reality is is that these these
these hydrogen protons they don't exist
in water on their own whenever they are
well in water and aqueous solution they
start to essentially get a ride with
another water molecule and that's what
happens here with a hydronium ion but
the whole reason why I'm going into this
whole discussion of the autoionization
of water is because people really care
about the concentration of depending on
I view it hydrogen atoms hydrogen
protons in a solution or you could say
hydronium protons in a solution the
concentration of these two things are
going to be the same right because all
of these really are riding on another
water molecule and becoming hydronium so
what how do you how do you measure this
or a better question is what is the
equilibrium of this reaction so it turns
out that in just regular water the
concentration and I'll maybe I'll switch
to this one the concentration of this is
in regular water at 25 degrees Celsius
let me write that down
25 degrees Celsius which is roughly room
temperature the concentrate which is
with pure water the concentration of
pure water in pure water the
concentration of hydrogen ions and you
could have also say that that's
concentration of hydronium ions or
cations because they're positive
it equals 10 to the minus seventh molar
right so for every for every for every
one liter of water you have 10 to the
minus seventh moles of hydronium ions
which is still a pretty good number
because it's 10 to the minus 7 moles so
it's 10 to the minus 7 times Avogadro's
number so let me just do that so it's 10
to the minus 7 moles per liter of water
which is the same thing as 10 to the
minus 7 times a mold is just number is
6.022
times 10 to the 23 so you turn
you you do the math here you still end
up with what 60 times 10 to the 16th
power molecules so you still have a
large number of molecules it's just a
small fraction of the total number of
molecules are actually are actually
these hydrogen or these hydronium ions
and it turns out that your concentration
of hydroxides is also so your
concentration of hydroxides is also ten
to the minus seventh molars so if we
know that we can now actually figure out
the equilibrium constant for this
autoionization of water we can figure
out the equilibrium constant so let's
let's do that and we'll do it the first
one so let's say you have I'll switch
colors h2o and aqueous solution it's in
equilibrium with hydrogen ions in an
aqueous solution but we know in reality
they've gotten rides with other with
other water ions with other water
molecules not ions they may turn them
into hydronium ions plus hydroxide
molecule the equilibrium for this
reaction the equilibrium constant we'll
call it for the K sub W for water it
equals the concentration of the products
of hydrogen ions times the concentration
of the hydroxide ions now in a normal
situation we would divided by the
concentration of the products but the
product of the reactants but in this
case and we learned this before the
reactants are what the solvent is we are
in water so we won't we won't include
this and if you want the intuition
behind that remember this whole thing
comes out from the probability of the
you know the bat this is the probability
of the backwards reaction happening is
related to the concentrations of these
two things multiplied by each other and
the probability of the forward reaction
happening or is related to is related to
the probability of finding two of the
product of the of the reactant molecules
in one space and you're always going to
find these molecules in some place
there's just going to be a constant
probability that some water
spontaneously turns into the into into
these two products so whenever you have
a
reaction like this equilibrium reaction
and the one side is essentially just a
solution you just don't include it so
the equilibrium so you or you can just
think of it as one down here so the
equilibrium constant of this
auto-ionization water is right there and
I just gave you what the numbers were at
room temperature so the equilibrium
constant is equal to the concentration
of hydrogen is 10 to the minus 7 plus
sorry times times the concentration of
hydroxide is also 10 to the minus 7 so
it equals 10 to the minus 14th power now
and that's a good thing to memorize the
the equilibrium constant of the
autoionization of water and all of this
is going to just so you know we're all
this is all going to lead into acids
because essentially people care a whole
bunch about what this concentration ends
up being and we're going to touch on
that a little bit in this video now it
turns out that people in chemistry they
for whatever reason they don't like
talking in these terms they don't like
saying 10 to the minus 14th power so
what they do is they take the negative
log of things negative log base 10 and
if logs are intimidating to you review
the videos on logarithms so what they do
is they take the minus log the minus log
of both sides minus log and what if
someone just writes log without a number
you can assume it's base 10 but they
take the minus log of the equilibrium
constant the minus log base 10 of 10 to
the minus 14 is equal to well 10 to what
power is 10 to the minus 14 well it's
minus 14 right and then you have that
minus in front you have this minus and
then the log part is just minus 14 is
minus 14 and so the minus log of the of
the equilibrium constant of water is
equal to 14 and this idea right here
this is called the PK w PK let me put
this the P and a and a different color
just so you see where it's PK w but all
P means whenever you see it in chemistry
just means minus log base 10 minus log
base 10 and there's some debate as to
what piece
and for I to think of it as power oh
that's a minus log it's an exponent but
whatever it means it's you're taking the
minus log of something and what it does
is it's just a kind of a a way to get
out of the exponent world although I
think it's nice your stay in the
exponent world because you really know
what you're talking about into some nice
clean number like 14 so when someone
says that the pkew is 14 all they're
saying is is that the equilibrium
constant which is just this part right
here is 10 to the minus 14 now the same
convention is used is used on the
hydrogen concentration and there's a lot
of the next few videos are all going to
revolve around the hydrogen
concentration in in water essentially
we'll talk a little bit about what
happens when you're outside of water now
the hydrogen concentration water at room
temperature or I've told you has been
determined to be 10 to the minus 7
molars people aren't happy just with
that so what they want to do is do the
same thing they want to take the minus
log of both sides and they defy so they
say the pH and you've probably heard the
word pH it's on a lot of cosmetics pH
balance now you know what it means
they're really just saying that we have
the right number of hydrogen ions in our
lotion or our perfume or whatever we're
trying to sell you so the pH is equal to
the minus log of the hydrogen of the
hydrogen ion concentration which is
equal to the minus log remember it's
just base 10 if I don't specify
otherwise of 10 to the minus 7 which is
equal to well the 10 to what power is 10
to the minus 7 this is equal to minus 7
then we have the minus outside so then
this becomes 7 now you can do that same
exercise for the Poh Poh the
concentration of hydroxide ions well
it's the negative log negative log of
the hydroxide concentration the
hydroxide concentration we saw was the
same concentration it's the water
concentration and I didn't write it
there where'd I write right there 10 to
the minus seventh molar so water has the
same number of hydroxides
and and hydrogen ions that's because
this water is just associating into the
two of them but of course this is equal
to minus minus seven right log based
this number right here is ten to the
minus seven so it equals seven so the pH
and the Poh of water is both equal to
seven now in the next few videos we're
going to start covering the notion of
acids and bases and it turns out that an
acid is just something that increases
the hydrogen concentration well that's
one version of acids we'll talk about
other broader definitions but it's
called the Arrhenius acid which we'll
talk about in the next video but if
something is making the hydrogen
concentration go up if we put something
in water that makes that go up what's
that going to do to the pH well if this
number right here goes up then the log
of that number is going to go up but
then the minus log of that number so
let's say for example you know ten to
the minus seven that's all good but
let's say we we take it from 10 to the
minus 7 so it tend to minus seven that's
kind of just neutral water doing nothing
we have a pH pH is 7 we just figured out
this calculation this where the hydrogen
concentration is equal to 10 to the
minus 7 now let's say we were to do
something to the water where the
hydrogen concentration were to increase
so we add hydrogen we add concentration
of hydrogen to let's say 10 to the minus
3 this is obviously a much higher
concentration of hydrogen than that
so the hydrogen concentration is now 10
to the minus 3 what's our new pH so the
new pH is going to be equal to the minus
log base 10 of 10 to the minus 3 that's
equal to that minus their 10 to the
minus 3 power is equal to 10 to the
minus 3 so it's minus 3 so this becomes
plus so now our pH is equal to pH is
equal to 3 so the big takeaway from this
is we care about the hydrogen
concentration when something increases
the hydrogen concentration that is
considered an acid and that when you and
when you increase the hydrogen
concentration when you put an acid into
aqueous solution you are lowering the pH
so the lower the pH the more acidic you
have in or the higher concentration of
hydroxide ion of hydrogen protons you
have and we'll talk in the next video
about the opposite of that with which is
basic things and bases increase the
concentration of hydroxide anyway see
you in the next video